[Music]
even great to be sat next to the legend
himself mr. Robert Kiyosaki and I am
truly honored to be able to sit on this
stage and ask Robert some questions so
most of the questions have been put in
from you guys so I have some right here
and we'll get some pearls of wisdom so
firstly have you enjoyed dinner Robert
that's a great dinner thank you very
much
awesome so we want to know we've had
dinner with you but we want to know what
kind of a morning you typically have so
a question that came in from Rocky who
flew in from Germany to be here for
dinner rocky here he is morning rituals
you have and what a typical day looks
like for you but five or six years ago I
wrote a book called miracle morning guys
fantastic book so I can up I do real
brief stretching little yoga and then I
meditate for half an hour and then I
read a spiritual book although what I
really want to read are financial books
but I take that that first hour in the
morning is to just calm me down for the
day and it's tremendous difference in
the health well that happens that's what
I do
fantastic next question this came from
Sandy what can the next generation do to
prosper as we enter an age of artificial
intelligence there's more opportunity
than ever before I don't know what
people are crying about yep
as I said I sue remember flying from
Hawaii landing and landing in California
getting off the plane in Denver having a
pocketful of quarters trying to make a
phone call into New York City to get an
appointment and if they were there I
could turn around and head back and so
my pockets were full of waters and
things like that it's so easy today I
just think people are lazy that's my
only thing I see opportunity every
single day but if you're trying to be an
employee and look for a job you won't
see anything so that you know I guess I
just can't believe that people can't see
opportunities so that's that's what I'm
the same yeah great I think we're living
in a massive land of opportunity
you talk a lot about a crash that's
coming and how you can actually make
money in a crash what would you say
advice would you give to the average
person what kind of signs should they be
looking for and how can they prepare
themselves for a crash well I don't know
what the big this crashes every 10 years
what's the big deal the difference is
you know sandy and I talk about this all
the time this next one is my baby I
can't just be prepared for it I mean I
you know my wife my wife and I I started
buying gold back in 1973
millions of dollars in gold coins I
don't have dollar bills and they're
stored outside the US so I'm not really
religious but I heard you know they poor
people build their house on sand and
rich people building their albums on
rock so the people who have built their
lives upon sand which is the US dollar
or the pound or the Europe do get wiped
out had this question the sky has today
I could have believed but he says well
when do you spend your goal I said to
him never and he just couldn't believe
my answers that gold is the foundation
of my life and that goal will be passed
on for generations I don't ever plan
expected that I think the question he
asked when the expended was probably the
most telling part about it is he wanted
to spend it and I use gold and silver
real gold and silver
that's foundation and I never plan on
spending I inquire more and more every
year when the price goes down I buy more
of it so to me gold and silver I'm right
about it and faith have been here since
the earth was born that's why I call it
God's money and the US dollar has only
been around a couple of hundred years
it's not gonna be here much longer and
so Americans are saving it which makes
no sense to me that's how stupid they
are I really are stupid why would you
save a piece of paper
that they're printing every single day
and the interest rate on it keeps coming
down which means one when I when I
graduated from school I got fifty
percent interest on my money today I'm
lucky if I get 2% they just showed you
how worthless cash has become and yet
people will tell people to save money I
just want to save gold and silver keep
it outside of the banking system in a
private fault one part of it close by
and the other parts country is unknown
let's do it legal because you can move
money illegally and you can move it
legally but just think of the three pigs
you know the story of one person built
our house out of what straw sticks and
brick so my house is on a foundation of
gold and silver no ETFs that's fake
money fake oh I bought my first gold
coin in 1972 in Hong Kong was a
Krugerrand and I paid about fifty
dollars for today that Krugerrands worth
1,300 so what happened did a Krugerrand
get bigger what did the purchase
purchasing power of the dollar go down
and if you know I was just talking to
somebody today in in 1999 gold was 260
an ounce today is 1300 an ounce you
think about that I mean what has
happened to the dollar so you just look
at the trend I'd rather have much real
that was fake a lot of people that read
Rich Dad Poor Dad I mean I read the book
when I was 16 and it was the first book
I ever read as I told you earlier and
introduced me to the whole world of
investing everybody's ready Rich Dad
Poor Dad it seems that they all have to
read in it go on to invest or wanting on
to invest a question for you is if you
were starting all over again and you had
just a hundred thousand dollars to
invest
what would you invest it in and why well
I wrote about a fake it's called an
infinite return I took I took a real
estate course back in 1973 and I learned
how to invest without money so all of my
investments are infinite which means I
have none of my money in any of my deals
I started the rich dad company with zero
I have no money in the rich dad company
and it does about 12 million a year with
no money
that's real financial intelligence so
it's called an infinite return which
means you don't have any money in the
deal and I cover that in faith it's easy
to do because each is easier to do in
the stock market very easy to do so the
idea that you need money is really shows
a lack of financial intelligence because
if the Fed can make it up the Treasury
can make it up so can you but it's just
a way JW could say it's just how you
look at it it's fake money so I just
make it up so you wouldn't need the
hundred thousand you be successful
anyway without it I use it for toilet
paper but that's about it you know
interesting I mean what would you say
there's a lot of people that would say
that sounds too good to be true or you
can't make money without money and
obviously you disagree with that what
would you say to them
why don't ever disagree with them I'm at
I'm talking to somebody who's was very
limited by God gave me this mind he can
make it up so I'm not killing you
Rich Dad Poor Dad was started in 1997 I
raised a quarter two hundred fifty
thousand dollars for it and we paid
everybody back in three years
it floats now and nothing this is air
and it throws off about 12 million a
year all of my real estate deals I have
no money in my real estate deals at all
so that's why I cover and fake so the
money that I do make since I don't need
the cash I don't want cash goes into
gold and silver so it's called an
infinite returns in the book talking of
books we've got the question here from
curry and she asked you though here
awesome
she says what's the book that you like
to gift your friends and family
what's your favorite book I don't even
know I mean I read so many what I say
the people is people say do what you
love but I say invest in what you like
and I love real estate I love
entrepreneurship I love oil and I love
gold and silver
I don't really fix them and I just read
what what I love so my question for you
is if you were starting again from
scratch with nothing what would be the
very first thing that you would do when
I start a company you start company I'd
work you know what I sit at young people
find something you'd like to do and do
it for free go work for somebody for
free don't work for that money the
moment you do that your soul just sold
your body mind soul there's so many
people I know they I was talking to
Brian Rose today those he does London
real he was a derivatives trader he said
he'd come home sick making a lot of
money there's a lot of people coming
home sick every single day because they
sold their soul for the money and so
he's he's much happier teaching today
and I see that the young people you know
just go work for something free the
reason I got into this business of
teaching his I see there was a company
like like Richard and product of tan I
just worked for free and volunteer and
every time I volunteered I learned more
so I I've been working for free for most
of my life because I don't need the
money
it's funny when I when I work for free
magic happens anyway what advice would
you give to a young Robert Kiyosaki I
don't ruin things I would do it all over
again and one of the biggest mistakes
that schools tell you don't make
mistakes like don't make mistakes how do
you learn it yeah you know baby doesn't
learn to a while unless they fall down
what our society punishes you for making
mistakes and then you have guys like
Bill Clinton the president United States
you know I mean you see he lies in front
of people's I didn't have sex
with that woman you know what is well
why do we have to lie getting a you know
what at the White House is not a crime
lying is and because so many people are
afraid to admit they made a mistake they
lie yeah and then wastes the most
important aspect of learning because you
made a mistake
so bucketful are used to say but there's
mistakes only sins but not admitted so
if you've made a mistake you don't have
a minute you've wasted a cent you know
you just wasted so I've made so many
horrible mistakes and that's how I get
smarter true yeah how you eye to success
yeah okay we've got a question from
Chris and Chris says what type of doubts
do you have nowadays and how do you deal
with them doubts yeah I don't think I
have any different attitude you know
like nobody wants to fail I don't like
failing but what I say to people is this
the higher the risk of what you're
taking on
the smarter you've got to be so if I'm
taking on something with extremely high
risk it just means I have to study more
and learn more ask more it's more
exciting that way and and then when I
fail which I do constantly I said good I
found out what did it work
I'm starting a new company so it was
very exciting you know I mean am I gonna
fail yes but what I fail I'm smarter
that's the attitude I've had for a long
time anyway I guess that's a similar
question this is from Vincent Shen and
he says what are your biggest challenges
right now and their biggest challenges
that you faced and how have you ever
come them exercising here I mean guys
when you're young exercise when you get
older it gets harder so that's the
raisin again
you know I used to love to exercise but
now I'm older and it's harder
you've obviously changed a lot of
people's philosophy and helped an awful
lot of people when it comes to finances
what do you want to be remembered for
apart from helping people with their
financial literacy that's a good I don't
really think about it I just remember
when I was studying with buck-buck
Minister for I studied with him three
times 81 82 83 and at that time I was in
the rock and roll industry and I was
doing what people said to do you know do
what you love and so rock and roll was
sex drugs rock and roll I don't do drugs
but I was trying for the sex I didn't
like
so I was working for the bands Duran
Duran a police van Halen boy George
it was so much fun making a lot of money
and so the third time I was studying at
foolery
he asked me says what's what what are
you doing I'm making a lot of money and
he just said a waste of a good mind just
to make money and he said something to
me which I never forgot he says why
don't you do what God wants done I said
what do you mean what God wants is sit
down and figure out what does God want
done and do it it wasn't what I wanted
to do and that's where most people are
at they're doing what they want to do
versus what God wants done so the more I
thought about this you know like if I
could cure cancer I'd be on it today but
I don't think I have the skill set to do
that so what I did know he came out with
this book right after that it's called
the Grunch of giants gross concepts of
girls - no personal cash points
it's how the ultra-rich ripped us off
and I said I think I can do that and
then I said maybe I should teach people
about money because I was already on
that path so I just remember what dr.
Martin Luther King said it's the same
the same thing
Siddalee King didn't say do what God
wants done what King says I just want to
do God's will what does God want done
so Martin Luther King gave his life
because he didn't think God wanted
people to be discriminated against
blacks so it really to give his life to
end discrimination and so when known and
that's the benefit I got from going to
military school and flying for the
Marine Corps is we did what we had to do
and many people just want to have fun
just make a few bucks go on vacation and
that's their choice but it kind of
messed me up what does God want done and
I have more than enough money but I keep
going because I don't think God wants
poverty I don't know I'm not speaking of
generic and signatures generic God I
don't think God wants poverty I don't
think God likes it there's a gap between
the rich and everybody else and so
that's why I do what I do so it's the
one I retire because I haven't done my
job yet or as Martin Luther King says I
just want to do God's will that's all
probably keep doing this like I I don't
need the money but I need to keep doing
what God wants done and we need to be
bought as human beings so that's why JW
and I talk about meditation and all that
is because men especially need to mutate
right g-dub
if we don't if we don't find more peace
inside ourselves we're gonna kill each
other you know I can't understand why
kids will go into school and kill other
kids
there's something very sick inside our
society I don't know why we're still in
the Middle Ages telling people you know
but it's what you essentially cover 120
million people so technology has evolved
but human beings have not so that's why
we can only speak about spirituality and
things like that because if as men and
as leaders we don't speak out that other
men will not do the same
what does spirituality mean to you
because I've heard you say quite a lot I
just want to do God's will that can
leave you with something to think about
that
that's all I focus on in faith I say you
gotta look for real teachers most
teachers are fake they're called
financial planners it's called school
teachers what you want to do is find
somebody who has done what you want to
learn the power of the human spirit
we've lost our soul we've really lost
our souls no money
and you know I know money is important
for most people but I gotta pass it so
that's why I decided to start saying
something JW is saying something we've
got to get off of this make money at all
the costs and screw anybody for the
money so that's why we do what we do and
I teach not because I need the money but
because I need to teach if there's a big
difference well I think I can sound
behalf of everybody thank you ever so
much and thank you for writing the book
Rich Dad Poor Dad
incredible
[Applause]
you